When does salah become further for a
person? Is it the age of puberty or age
of 10? Number two, what should we do
about missed prayers? I unfortunately
missed prayers for years. Should we just
repent or cover it? And if I must cover
it, how many years should I cover?
Because I became adult in 14 and now I'm
15. Should I cover just one year or five
years?
The question
posed by iman from Afghanistan is
that at what age does it become fur for
a person to offer salah? Is it the age
of puberty or the age of 10? First the
name
iman is also of a girl also of a boy. So
I don't know whether the question posed
by the questioner is it a male or is it
a female is it a girl or is it a boy you
know that you are 15 years old but we
don't know whether you're a girl or a
boy because iman is a name used for a
boy as well as for a girl but irrespect
what it is the correct age at which the
salah becomes f is at the age of puberty
and the age of puberty
differs between different people between
different sex whether it's male or
female whether you're coming from a cold
country or a hot country whether you're
living in India or Afghanistan or USA it
differs if you're a girl the right age
is at puberty when you start having
menstrual cycle a girl can start having
menstrual cycle even normally it's
between the age of 13 14 sometime it can
be even 12 it can even be 10 I doctor
I'm aware that girls even at the age of
nine they start the menstrual cycle. So
the day a girl starts having menstrual
cycle is the day she reaches puberty and
from that time it becomes further than
her to prophet salah and for a boy also.
So the average age may be 13 14 sometime
it can be late to the age of 15 and
since you said that you reach puberty at
the age of 14 so from that time salah
becomes for you if you're a boy but
naturally from the time you start having
pubic hair and the signs of puberty come
that is the time when salah becomes and
for a boy also it's similar it may be
the age of 14 can be 15 can be 13 it
varies between individuals so as far as
you are concerned since you said that
you read the age of puberty at the age
14 then your salah becomes fur from the
age of 14 and he said that now you're 15
so you missed your fur the salah for 1
year not 5 years a question that should
you cover up or should you catch up or
should you make up for the fur the salah
that you have missed for the past 1 year
or should you just repent there are two
opinions for this there's one opinion we
say that you should make up for it and
as many times as you offer your zohar or
assura at the same time you keep on
offering an additional for the time that
you have missed. This is one opinion but
the more correct opinion is that if you
have missed the salah intentionally and
purposefully there is no experation. Our
beloved prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said mentioned in hadith of say
bkari in say Muslim that if a person
forgets to offer salah there's no
explanation and the moment he remembers
he should offer it another says that if
a person sleeps and doesn't offer salah
the moment he wakes up the moment he
remembers he should offer there's no
explanation for that the moment he wakes
up he should offer salah so based on
these and various hadith the prophet was
very emphatic clear that if you forget
if you miss your salah because of
forgetfulness or because you're sleeping
salah you sleep so there's no excitation
for it and the moment you remember it
you should pray immediately you should
not wait till your next salah is there
immediately and Allah will not hold
responsible the Muslim on that so the
second opinion which is the correct
opinion of the scholars is that if you
miss it intentionally out of laziness or
saying okay I'll meet after after the
time is over or you know it is further
you may only offer once in a day or may
not offer at all for many years
according to the second opinion which is
the book right opinion there is no
expiration for the salah that you have
intentionally missed it is a major sin
so if you intentionally miss any salah
it's a major sin and the Only remedy for
this is that you repent to Allah subhana
wa t'ala. You ask for forgiveness from
Allah subhana wa t'ala and you repent
and inshallah Allah will forgive you and
to compensate for that which you have
missed. There's no explanation but the
scholars say that you can increase your
salah your sunnah salah the sunnah the
sunnah you increase that and do more
good deeds for example give more charity
give more of
donation so do more good deeds which
will compensate for the sins you have
done but you don't have to repeat the
salah you have missed and this is the
more correct and authentic opinion which
was even followed by the second khalif
of Islam that
is may Allah be pleased with him
including his son Abdah Omar and various
sahabas so there are various hadith that
reaffirms that it's a sin and there is
no compensation like you don't have to
repeat your salah it's a sin you have to
ask for forgiveness and this was a view
which was also there by may Allah merc
Even all the scholars even the
contemporary
scholmani all of them say that if you
miss your salah intentionally then you
don't have to repeat it you have to ask
for forgiveness and do more good deeds
whe the charity more of salah more of
the sunnah salah and this is the opinion
even those people who say that you have
to They don't say that once you read it
is like if you have forgotten and if you
offer your salah immediately you will
remember there's no sin. They don't say
that if you have missed and if you offer
salah there's no sin. They say that it's
a major sin but if you read then your
sin becomes less but the mo like opinion
is what I gave earlier that you don't
have to repeat it because imagine
suppose you realize at the age of 50
that I should offer salah and the time
that you had to offer salah was when you
became an adult when you reach maybe at
the age of 14. So now you say for 36
years I did not offer salah now if I
have to read for all the 36 years will I
live that long? So maybe you say okay
since I did not read salah for 36 years
I will not read for the rest of the
life. So logically also it doesn't make
sense you have to ask for forgiveness.
Inshallah Allah will forgive you. You
can read as many more sunnah
salah and do other would be like extra
fasting and giving more charity. So this
opinion which is more authentic opinion.
So for you also you missed your salah
for one year because you reached at the
age of 14 but you don't have to repeat
those salah which you missed for one
year just to that you
increase your
mada in the last oneird of
night fast move give more charity
inshallah may Allah subhanaa tala
forgive you and may Allah's increase in
your blessings hope that answers the